c'est la plus grande ville des
États-Unis une ville où on se targue
constamment d'être à l'avant-garde en
matière de mode de cuisine
d'architecture et maintenant sur le plan
sanitaire
de spectacle
ayant reçu au moins une dose de vaccin
contre le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qu'un
petit d'entreprise à rester ouverte
celle-ci
comment se fait-il pas retrouvé leur vie
d'antan en fait ce qui recherche le plus
sont les restaurateurs humain aime
personnellement parce que je suis pas
policier on a du bon moment on a pas
envie de demander aux gens de sortir
leurs téléphones nous montrer 600
vacciné ou pas si ils sont ils sont 8
personnes il y a un truc c'est qu'il est
pas ça va être ça va être compliqué
certaines salle de spectacle ne semble
pas non plus très enthousiaste
plus de se faire vacciner
froide au propriétaire d'établissement
poussins les salaires à la hausse et
réduisant les profite c'est sans compter
l'augmentation du prix des aliments et
la nécessité de rembourser les dettes
contractées durant la pandémie ici
Radio-Canada New York